Here's another movie recommendation, if you like squid
game, i think you'll like this too.
Exam is a movie where eight strangers who all applied
to the same job make to the final round of the interview
process, where they all have to take an exam.
The invigilator, who is basically in
charge, tells them a set of rules and says that he will not repeat them,
and if you break any of the rules, you will be disqualified.
He walks out of the room and the exam begins
where they have eighty minutes to answer one question.
As a clock starts to
count down, they all flip over their paper and it's blank.
They have 80 minutes to answer one question, but there is no
question, so everything starts to go a little bit crazy from there.
But everybody in the room decides to interpret his
rules, like if he didn't say it, we can do it.
example, i can murder this person because
he never said that we couldn't murder anybody.
Throughout this whole movie,
i was trying to guess what the question was and what the answer might be.
Nope, i feel like only people with a
lot of common sense can get this,
but it was really hard.
I think i have a good amount of common sense and i did not get it.
I thought it was a really good movie.
Although there's this one guy who was like, racist and sexist, and
instead of using real names, he decides to call everybody by
nickname, so he calls himself white and somebody else, black, brown,
blondie, brunette.
Don't root for him.
Um, anyways, i
thought i got a little crazy for people
who were literally just like fighting over a job.
But if you guys want to watch it, it's on amazon prime.
I definitely think it's worth the watch.